- All right. Welcome back.
I'm here with Margaret
Cho and Rex Chapman.
Give it up!
(audience applause)
So, Rex is known the king of viral videos.
So we wanted to play a game we're calling,
"Wait For It."
♪ Wait for it ♪
All right so here's how it works.
Rex will show us the first
few seconds of a video
he's recently posted.
All we have to do is
guess what happens next.
So, okay.
I'm gonna fail at this. Oh gosh.
Okay.
So what should we know about
this first one, you think?
- Well, I believe this first one is
a guy just shredding down the slope.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It's like Aspen, could
be anywhere, I guess.
But he's pretty prolific at it.
- Okay.
- And let's watch and
see what happens next.
- Okay. Okay.
- Right.
- I love this sound of that powder.
- Normally I show videos
with people running
into each other, maybe
bumping into one another.
What do we think happens here?
Is it a dog?
Is it an animal that runs out?
What happens? Anybody?
- I feel like he's just gonna bust.
Like, he's gonna try and
do something cool and bust.
- Margaret, what do you think?
- I think he's going to
just walk off of the board.
- Really?
- That's what it seems like.
- [Kelly] I've snowboarded
and you're locked in.
I don't know.
- I think he's gonna walk off the board.
- Okay. Okay.
Well wait for it.
Let's see what happens.
- Okay.
(Kelly screams)
(audience clapping)
- What?
- Pretty cool.
- Yeah.
- Could you ever?
- No!
- [Rex} Not a chance.
- Never!
- I have worked so hard for my life.
I'm not giving it away
for some cliff jump.
Like what?
I did not see that coming.
- No, no.
- I'm not a thrill seeker.
Are you a thrill seeker?
- I'm not.
I could never jump out of a plane.
- Why?
Unless it's going down
and it's my only option.
Yeah. No.
Okay. Well you brought another one.
That's gonna scare the crap outta me.
Here we go.
Let's check it out.
(cheering)
- Now. We all know.
We've all seen the people at graduations.
- Graduation. Yeah.
- That get a little overly
exuberant from time to time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- All right, well, this
guy is one of those guys.
- Okay.
- And what do we think happens next?
- I feel like he's maybe gonna fall
over that rail is what I think.
Is that what you said too?
I feel like he's gonna
get so excited he falls.
- I don't know.
I mean, I think he might get a diploma?
- He might get one too.
- Yeah. Maybe he'll get-
- I need one.
It would be my first.
Let's see what happens.
- Oh my God.
(cheering)
Oh my God.
Oh my God wait.
Did you see him do like a
mini typewriter MC Hammer?
That was like mini typewriter
move from MC Hammer.
- He did.
- That was amazing.
Okay, let's talk about how
he just gymnastics his way
back on up.
- I know.
Great upper body strength, right?
- Or core!
If someone said you will die
unless you do this, I'd die.
I couldn't do that.
- I wish I'd had done that
to kids at their graduation.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
My kids would hate me.
- Me too-
- [Kelly] But wouldn't it be fun.
- but only for a little while.
Only for a little.
- Well, thank you so much Rex.
- Thank you guys.